everybody should be able to be made fun
of everybody should be able to take a
job and if you can't
don't watch it
[Music]
[Music]
i feel he's comedian media is going to
offend everybody and anyone i mean
that's his job yeah you can't take
everything to heart
honestly if making fun of one specific
group is off the table
i mean
that's just kind of
i don't know i'm not right i'm not a
home person
a community
can rule over comedy
music
and cancel people and people taking the
cancer culture too far they're going to
tell you how they think that's what's
got them here and that's what's going to
change
we live in a free country he goes after
everybody it's not just aimed at one
group
he's not as
negative
feelings
getting caught into comedy and it's just
the times of changing to where everybody
is taking things more seriously than
what they're supposed to be you can
teach each other to do better
look it's america he has a platform he's
being able to perform
however he wants to do it
and i mean the show's sold out obviously
it's not effective to do that definitely
don't see him being apologetic
maybe he shouldn't be yeah i think it
started uh addressing uh important
issues
but uh many people went overboard and so
now i think society is
working against it it's having a bad
view i think that everything's a
double-edged sword there's good and bad
it's just what you're chasing
that's ridiculous i mean
people are getting cancelled for doing
absolutely nothing wrong
i don't know a lot of these people
aren't bad people either they just say
one thing 10 years ago
get their job and their life taken from
them so you can't bowl
[Music]
you